can't figure you out there Eoin that's
because I work hard to hide who I really
am
if soon find out who you care for who
you love
he'll take them from you you can't keep
things from her forever
then that's what I'll do I'll tell fatty
in this fashion
hey youtubers it's Charlie so that was a
trailer for the flash episode 10 and we
now know that it's going to be the
mirror master episode so let's break
this down just talking about the footage
itself it's all about Patty's still not
knowing Barry's secret him wanting to
tell her in Harrison wells of Earth to
saying whoa way too dangerous dude pump
the brakes
if zoom finds out who you love he'll try
to use it against you just in the way
that he took Jessie quick from Harrison
wells so what else is going on in here
you see Barry wearing a slightly
different outfit and Paddy looking a
little bit different I think this is
still earth one Barry and Patty now
there been some pictures from the set I
don't know which episode exactly that
they're filming but it shows Caitlin
snow as killer frost and it seems like
Barry is with her wearing this same type
of outfit so a lot of people thought
that this might be earth to Barry but I
still think that it's very just wearing
a slightly different outfit I know we're
all wondering where earth to Barry is
like is he dead is he in prison what's
going on but it's just a continuation of
zoom throwing earth two villains against
Barry to make him stronger to make him
more full of Speed Force we also have to
remember that Harrison wells agreed to
help zoom to save his daughter so I'm
kind of wondering if he's gonna slip
some velocity-9
into Barry's drink so to speak just to
make him super fast it sounds like it
took Harrison wells all of last year
like all of the year before he came to
earth one to get to that six iteration
so I'm guessing it's gonna take most of
the back half of the season for him to
get from velocity six to velocity nine
so it's probably gonna take a little
while to get there but what about mirror
master that's actually a really big deal
the only other rogue that I know of that
they said they're gonna do but haven't
said when is dr. alchemy your very
different types of powers but it seems
like if this is going to be mirror
master like he's not listed on the IMDB
page but they have released a
description saying it's the mirror
master episode so I'm guessing that this
is him I've already done a video
explaining mirror masters backstory so
I'll add a link in the description but
there are really two big versions of the
character there's the Sam Scudder mirror
master and then there's the Evan
McCullough mirror master now either
McCulloch is more Jeff John Sara so I'm
thinking that they probably go with him
what I really want to know is how
they're gonna treat the mirror world
because they might just align the mirror
world with earth to like use the
mirrored dimension as a way to travel
between earths but I think they want to
make it seem like the portal beneath
STAR Labs is going to be the only portal
to earth 2 so I still feel like they're
gonna do the mirror dimension the mirror
dimension is
a bit of a question mark itself because
on the surface the description sounds a
lot like Earth - it was like a flip
version of our world now in the comics
there is like an alternate race of
beings that live in the mirror world
like that the weird world of the Silver
Age comics the mirror dimension is just
what Geoff Johns was calling it when he
started writing the title but my guess
is it's gonna be like a twisted shadow
version of Earth one but but don't think
of it in the way you think of earth -
they're pretty good of making really big
concepts like that seem really simple on
the TV show so you'll be you'll be able
to follow pretty easily and what they
might even do is just kind of collapse
the idea and just have him travel
between mirrors which is how his powers
work it's just that the space between
the mirrors is the mirror dimension let
me know in the comments though like what
do you want to see them do with the
mirror master character they've done a
really good job of letting the flash
defeat the Rogues like especially the
big roads without killing them I know I
know there been a couple questionable
kills early in the season but the better
the character the longer they try to
keep them on so even if they get taken
down by the flash they could always come
back later
speaking of which people said that if
the heroes and villains fanfest David
Ramsey who plays Diggle of all people
said that King shark is coming back to
the flash season 2 which makes sense
like they did Grodd once early in the
season then they brought him back in a
really big way so just expect to see
king shark again and because Diggle was
talking about it I'm wondering if it's
gonna be like a minor crossover with
arrow characters King freaking shark
that was one of the most comic-book
things that they've done all season long
just pure comic book moment giant
freaking shark you guys may have seen me
posting images from the sex scene that
Barry and Patti had in a recent episode
it's just a deleted scene from episode 9
it takes place before the Christmas
party because you know he's inviting her
to the Christmas party that was nice
I'm laughing because you decided to mix
glycerol with an oxidizing agent for
your 7th grade science fair project why
after the shock of realizing that there
is all kinds of crazy sex happening on
the flash that we're not getting there's
hitting the cutting room floor really
what's going on here is she tells him
about Mark Martin killing her father so
she's coming clean with her secret Barry
is getting ready to come clean with his
secret but it's mostly meant to be like
a relationship comedy scene where she's
like oh hey you know I can go for some
ice cream and barry super-speeds out to
get ice cream and then comes back with
it we learned her favorite flavor
is vanilla very loaded Comet that you
can make fun of that as much as you want
but the other thing is that berry has a
picture of his dead mother sitting right
next to his bed so even funnier that his
dead mother was watching them have sex
good thing they didn't start talking
about their dead parents before they had
sex now I would have been taking things
in a really weird direction you can
thank slash blame Andrew Kreisberg for
writing this but then not letting it
make it to the screen like there's all
kinds of scenes that hit the cutting
room floor so it's probably gonna be on
the DVD I know it's still a bit of a WTF
hearing about Caitlin snow killer frost
still thinking that's going to be earth
- Caitlin based on some of the images
we've seen from the set I'm not gonna
post them here just because there's some
weird ownership attribution stuff going
on but suffice to say the costume looks
just like this so unless something
really dramatic happens to earth one
Caitlin it seems like this is gonna be
earth - Caitlin way back early at the
beginning of the season when we met
earth - Harrison wells and he outed
Cisco's a metahuman his detector did not
detect Caitlin as a metahuman despite
the fact that earth 1 Harrison wells
eobard thawne said that she was affected
by the particle accelerator explosion
maybe they just dropped it in the
writers room or they decided they wanted
to take the Caitlin from earth one in a
slightly different direction but if you
go back and watch the flash season 1
finale
eobard thawne says that he suspects that
Caitlin and Cisco were affected by the
blast but I guess we want to get really
technical about it then you know
everybody was inside that blast radius
not everybody got metahuman powers the
really simple bye line that I've been
seeing is that like everybody who is a
metahuman on earth one is not a
metahuman on earth - in vice-versa so
like Linda Park totally normal on earth
1 honor to the particle accelerator
exploded gave her metahuman powers so
same thing for all the other characters
which makes me wonder like about earth -
patty like all these other characters
now I'm still doing the reverse flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video because they
have a little extra time this weekend
I'm probably gonna do a Batman V
Superman Q&A video I'll just announce
the winner of the ring in that video if
you guys really want me to do an arrow
trailer video I'll do that too so just
let me know what you guys want in the
comments below all kinds of crazy stuff
happening if you guys haven't seen it
yet you can click here for my latest
Star Wars trailer and you can click here
for
the x-men apocalypse trailer if you
haven't seen that yet thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
Oh